all right happy monday everybody well
it's going to be a little gamble on the
winds and how strong they'll be in your
neighborhood today we've had south
southwest winds sometimes southeast
winds and they've been up to 20 25 30
even 35 miles an hour at times in
isolated neighborhoods not all but man
the wind in the mountains has been
ferocious now we are expecting to get
some dust and i'm already starting to
see some dusty areas across southern
nevada this morning angel peak that's up
around 8 800 feet in the spring
mountains has had a near 80 mile per
hour wind gusts that was just about an
hour or so ago kyle canyon near 50 mile
per hour winds back at midnight but
they've been consistently up around 45
miles an hour mountain springs summit
quite windy as well as well as the
beltway out there on the west side and
far west summerlin we've got a lot of
60s around the valley few neighborhoods
in the upper 50s mid 50s for seven hills
mountains edge at 58 56 at red rock 35
mile per hour winds out there at red
rocks gonna be a rough morning to get
out and ride the bike around the loop or
do some hiking today so please be extra
careful or maybe wait a day until the
winds back down under 60 in mesquite 49
up in caliani 52 at indian springs low
50s in front 54 in searchlight and 60s
in laughlin reno had a little rain and
snow overnight and the wind chill up
there is around 30 degrees it's all
around a cold front bringing some rain
and snow into california and nevada look
at that nice snow up there in northern
nevada this is really pretty much all
lifting to the north and there won't be
a ton of moisture left with it by the
time that cold front pushes through
later this morning wind advisories went
into effect overnight
late last night for the mountains that
will expire for the mountains before
noon but for the valley all of those for
the lower elevations will last until
five o'clock tonight we're going to be
cooler today yesterday was 83 today
we're looking at 70 degrees maybe could
even be 69 so it is going to be quite a
cool down the winds will back off by
late today into tonight and much lighter
winds tuesday but still cool at 71
mornings in the 40s for a couple of
mornings and then we'll get back up to
81 by friday a very pleasant weekend too
on the way